one measure of an actor may be said to
be his willingness not to conceal
himself but to show himself in all his
humanity and to expose both the light
and the darker sides of his nature
openly and truly the nominees for a
performance by an actor in a leading
role or Robert De Niro in taxi driver
Peter Finch in network
giancarlo Gina Neely in seven beauties
William Holden in this work Sylvester
Stallone in Rocky
and the winner
if Peter Finch in network accepting the
award for the late Peter Finch mr. paddy
Chayefsky
some obscure reason I'm up here
accepting an award for Peter Finch or
finchy at everybody who knew him called
him there is no reason for me to be here
there's only one person should be up
here accepting this award and that's the
person who Finch wanted up here
accepting his award mrs. Peter Finch are
you in the house Aleta come up and get
your award
I want to say thanks the members of the
Academy and my husband I wish he was
here tonight to be with us all but since
he isn't here
I'd always cherish this for him and
before he died he said to me darling if
I win I want to say thanks to my fellow
actors who have given me encouragement
over the years and thanks to Parrish I
have skied who have given him the part
and thanks to Barry who tell us to come
from Jamaica to come and do this part
and he says most of all thanks to you
darling for sending the right vibes the
right way and thanks the members of the
Academy Award thank you
you